prime minister Rishi sunak has been
issued a fixed penalty notice by
Lancashire police for not wearing a seat
belt in a moving car it's the second
time he's had a fixed penalty notice
from police and he's only the second
serving prime minister after Boris
Johnson to be fined by police while in
the position so should he consider his
position
no I don't think so if you look at the
context of it or indeed the context of
the earlier fine which was I mean very
much been a virgin Behavior but look the
Prime Minister has been very clear so
it's a mistake his books hand up people
want that kind of honesty he's
apologized he'll pay the fine it was an
inadvertent mistake and it shouldn't
have happened and he's been very clear
about that